charles oliveira came out and said he
wants connor
he's like i don't want to fight get you
let's bench gage and bring connor in and
then conor tweeted out would give me a
date
because charles goes listen man
this is when i'm in fight sports for
price fighting i want the most money
possible you're crazy if you don't think
i'd rather fight conor than gaijin he's
like does geisha deserve it sure but i'm
trying to make the most money off of
course give me connor dude i'm 100 on
this train
oh really [ __ ] yeah
i would love to see that you know the
ufc you know you remember the ufc's
entertainment prize fighting like that
make sense that's a better even though
he's lost too much
yeah
that might be a better fight for conor
than than dustin was i mean uh than
dustin priya was in a way i mean i don't
know you know what i mean like all tough
for connor at this point but yeah but
yeah
i mean you still do you think it'd be a
good fight though yeah yeah i'm all for
it yeah i hope you help it happens yeah
it makes no sense in any realm that we
live in he's just jumping the queue but
i'm a conor dick writer so please give
him a title shot yeah it makes no sense
and the entire mma communities can be
pissed but remember the casuals are
going to pay for a connor fight over a
gay of course but the hardcores are like
what the [ __ ] yeah dana's like my bank
accounts what the [ __ ] i i i would
consider myself a hardcore fan and i
don't care i i want the money for i want
that you want you want that [ __ ] yeah i
want to get paid the most i love that
[ __ ] guy yeah he's such a bad
[ __ ] um
can i get another picture of connor
right now he put on 36 pounds of muscle
i think that vehicle yeah and and and
that's that's from eating um six meals a
day you gotta eat a lot of
meals you can do it
holy [ __ ] yeah
uh-huh now he's not working right now
though right he in other words he's
training but he's not he's not he can't
do much leg stuff right now
because he broke his leg remember oh i
thought you're kidding because it's like
he's like so tiny no he broke his leg
yeah his legs are tight he can't do much
leg work right now
yeah
he's uh
he's definitely um
he looks fantastic
yeah it's a good look
yeah that's uh he's at 190
i don't think he's 190. that's what he's
saying they say i don't i don't think
he's one he's holding a lot of water in
his face and his his face got thicker
yeah it's going if you put on weight
you're facing sure
sure
yeah if you're going to put on weight
and i'm sure that that's awful that's
him at 45 literally on the death star
what a [ __ ] weird trend difference
that's so crazy that is so weird man he
looks like mike perry on the right huh
oh my god
yeah that's um good for him